[Music]
what is up everybody at Santa Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be talking about a pretty crazy
black clover theory that came to me
while reading the most recent chapters
of the manga please note this video is
not a spoiler it is a theory video about
the true origins of you know in hasta
and the real reason why the two of them
are so closely connected and why they
both have such unique talents and
abilities as of the making of this video
this theory has not been confirmed in
the manga but with that said this video
will contain manga spoilers because that
is the only way to give you all of the
evidence for why I think that this
theory might be true if you enjoy black
clover videos and you want to see more
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification valve
since the very beginning of black clover
we have wondered why hasta and you know
were dropped off at the same orphanage
as babies at the same exact time the two
of them certainly don't look alike so it
doesn't seem like they are twin brothers
or anything like that although it's not
impossible for twin siblings to look
completely different it is more rare
usually twins even fraternal twins will
have at least some clear similarities in
appearance with that said the guys over
at anime balls-deep have an interesting
theory about you know and hasta
potentially being twin brothers and the
children of licked and Tatia according
to this theory Tatia was actually
pregnant with twins but because she was
killed during the elf massacre her twins
were reincarnated as baby you know and
baby hasta i will link that video in the
description if you want to check it out
after this video it is definitely
interesting and they raised some really
cool points to support the theory with
the official translation of chapter 197
of the manga we saw that Raya says the
following about you know is it waking up
licked child inside him I think that
this can definitely be interpreted as
lending more credence to the theory that
you know and hasta might be licked and
Tania's children however just for fun in
this video I will propose an alternate
theory my argument is that when Raya
says licks child in chapter
197 what he means is that licks child is
the elf who possessed you knows human
body earlier in the story back when he
was first possessed the elf inside you
know did not wake up so you know retain
control of his body and gained the
ability to use elf magic but now it
appears that the elephant side of you
know licked unborn child is finally
waking up at least according to Raya but
moving on ever since they were dropped
off at the orphanage
hasta and you know developed a deep bond
and a great friendship and both of them
have the same goal to become the wizard
king but as the story goes on both hasta
and you know have also demonstrated some
very unique talents and abilities
abilities that have never really been
explained until now
in the most recent chapters of the manga
we meet a devil who revealed some
incredible new things to us about what
really happened during the elf massacre
500 years ago all this time we thought
that during the wedding between the
leader of the elves Licht and tete Tia
the human sister of the first wizard
King the elves were betrayed by humans
and they were all ambushed and
slaughtered grief-stricken and mad with
rage licked with his wife still in his
arms casts a forbidden spell called
reincarnation magic and this allows the
elves to be reincarnated at a future
date in order to exact their revenge on
the clover kingdom then allegedly
stricken with despair and thirsty for
revenge licked also summoned a demon God
sometimes referred to as the ancient
demon and this massive demon begins to
wreak havoc on the clover kingdom this
is the demon that is eventually defeated
by the first wizard king and the one
who's called still lies on the outskirts
of Haga village however in chapter 197
we learned that this is not what really
happened the devil tells Patri than in
reality Licht would never have wanted
the eradication of the humans after all
his wife was human and his unborn child
was half-human it was actually the devil
who reincarnated the elves and who
manipulated poetry to set into motion a
plan that licked himself would never
have approved
this of course changes everything and it
throws massive doubt on the idea that
licked summoned the demon God out of
revenge in fact the devil in Chapter 197
actually says that it was licked and the
first wizard king who somehow managed to
prevent the devil from incarnated into
the human world and his whole plan with
resurrecting the elves was related to
finding another way to complete his
incarnation at this point it looks like
the devil's master plan has come to
fruition perfectly and that the entire
world will now be at his mercy
except you know and hasta are still
there remember what the devil says about
licked and the first wizard king
preventing him from incarnated five
hundred years ago the two of them must
have done something to prevent the devil
from achieving his goal and they must
have been fully aware of the threat that
the devil was going to pose sometime in
the future even though he had not been
incarnated into this world he was still
the one who manipulated the humans and
orchestrated the massacre of the elves
and the devil is not the type of
creature to give up on his ultimate goal
to become incarnated into this world we
have to remember that it was around the
age of nine that William Van Jones first
began seeing Patras memories although it
took until he was about 16 for Patri to
fully awaken inside of him
this means that Patras reincarnation was
set into motion right around 17 years
ago and what happens just about one year
after that Austin you know are born and
dropped off at the orphanage in hog a
village we now know that Patras
reincarnation was set into motion by the
devil himself and I believe that the
birth of hasta and you know just a year
after that is no coincidence
I believe that licked and the first
wizard King knew that the devil will
eventually make his move and that he
will use forbidden reincarnation magic
to achieve what he failed to do five
hundred years ago and I believe that
licked and the first wizard king also
used forbidden magic to ensure that once
the devil makes his move they too would
be reincarnated so that they could stop
him and they were reincarnated as hasta
and you know I mean just look at that
eye color did you ever notice
that hasta has the exact same eye color
as the wizard King and you know has the
exact same eye color is licked I mean I
realized that I color isn't actually any
conclusive proof but if this is just a
coincidence it's a pretty big one the
truth is that the so-called reincarnated
licked in his artificial body is not the
real licked or to be more accurate he is
not the complete licked the real lick
that we know from flashbacks is very
different from the strange almost
soulless licked who possesses the
artificial body I believe that this is
because part of licked probably the most
important part currently resides inside
of you know licked was reincarnated
inside of you know and that is why you
know retained his own personality when
he was first possessed by an elf but
still managed to master elf magic so
easily and turn it to his own advantage
I also think that the child of licked
chose to enter you knows body for a
reason the child and the father have the
most compatible mana so that is why this
particular elf chose you know and this
also explains why you know has such
amazing magical talents just like Licht
had back when he was alive but what
about hasta
the first wizard King was known for
having amazing magical powers
so if asta is the reincarnation of the
wizard king why was he born without any
magic the answer to this question lies
within Austen's 5-leaf grimoire you will
recall that when the artificial Licht is
asked by Raya why he sent away his
grimoire Licht states that this grimoire
is no longer his that means that
something happened something important
led to Licht losing possession of his
own grimoire austin's grimoire was once
licked 4-leaf grimoire but somehow this
grimoire became a five leaf grimoire
once it was possessed by a demon or
devil in chapter 196 the devil says that
he used the bond between the mages
chosen by the four-leaf grimoires
presumably licked and the first wizard
king who both had four leaf grimoires in
order to create the grimoire of despair
and we can assume that when he says this
he is referring to asked us five leaf
grimoire but despite succeeding in
creating the five leaf grimoire the
devil failed
to use it to complete his incarnation
because licked and the first wizard king
managed to do something to stop him I
think that after the massacre of the
elves licked and the first wizard king
managed to take control of the 5-leaf
grimoire they somehow managed to
repurpose it and use it to stop the
devil from completing his plan at some
point the 5-leaf grimoire stopped being
the property of licked and i believe
that its ownership was transferred to
the first wizard king in order for
someone other than the devil to take
control of the 5-leaf grimoire a price
had to be paid and that price may be the
reason why asta was born without any
magic the first wizard king had to give
up all of his magic in order to take
ownership of the 5-leaf grimoire and
then 500 years later this same grimoire
chooses hasta a boy without any mana and
therefore without any magical power
precisely because he is the
reincarnation of the grimoires current
owner the first wizard king and because
the first wizard king had to give up his
magic to take ownership of the grimoire
his reincarnation hasta was also born
without any magic we know that the
unique power of the 5-leaf grimoire is
anti magic the ability to nullify magic
and because hasta was born without any
magical power it makes sense that he is
the owner because he is the only one who
is able to effectively use the 5-leaf
grimoire hasta is the only one who
already paid the price in order to use
it albeit in a former life and this is
why that part of leaked that is inside
the artificial body readily admits that
he is no longer the rightful owner of
this grimoire I believe that this five
leaf grimoire because it has a devil or
demon inside of it is actually closely
connected to demon activity and demon
magic and this connection allowed licked
and the first wizard King to cast a
reincarnation spell that would activate
once the devil's own reincarnation came
into effect and this is why you know and
hasta are born within a year of Patri
first beginning to awaken inside of
William von gence we have to remember
that the demons or Devils are ancient
beings
it is possible that the elves and the
humans have been at war with the demons
for hundreds or even thousands of years
if anyone would have understood the
threat posed by the devil
it would have been licked and the first
wizard King and if anyone would have
been capable of using ancient and
forbidden magic to reincarnate
themselves or part of themselves
sometime in the future in order to stop
the devil from carrying out his master
plan
it would have been leaked the leader of
the elves and the first wizard King the
greatest human wizard licked and the
first wizard king or at least some part
of them have been reincarnated into you
know and hasta and this explains why you
know and hasta were born at the same
point in time and in the exact same
place and that place is of course hog a
village the same place where the battle
between the first wizard king and the
demon God occurred and the very same
place where the 5-leaf grimoire was
created and so it is no wonder that five
hundred years later that same grimoire
was still located in that part of the
kingdom and waiting for hasta its former
owner to claim it in terms of how the
5-leaf grimoire might have been used to
foil the devil's plans in the past we
can't forget that the 5-leaf grimoire
actually allows hasta to use the demon
destroyer sword the demon destroyer
sword is unique because of its ability
to negate even forbidden magic such as
reincarnation magic so it is very likely
that the demon destroyer sword was how
licked and the first wizard king were
able to stop the devil from completing
his incarnation in the first place it is
also possible that the demon destroyer
sword will play a crucial role in
foiling the devil's plans in the present
time as well so even if the first wizard
king had to give up all of his magic in
this lifetime and the next just to be
able to use the five leaf clover the
unique abilities of the demon destroyer
sword seem like they would be worth the
sacrifice but that is just my current
theory for the secret origins of you
know and hasta in the connection between
them and leaked and the first wizard
king after all Asta's appearance does
have many similarities to the first
wizard king and you knows natural talent
is comparable to the incredible talent
that Licht was known for not to mention
that both you know and hasta seem to
share the ideals of licked and the
wizard king deep in there
and their ideals are that all creatures
both human and health and people of all
different social classes must come to
understand each other and live together
in peace only time will tell whether
this theory turns out to be true or
completely off the mark but that is part
of the fun with these types of videos
let me know what you guys think did you
agree with the theory or do you have a
different take about the origins of you
know and hasta please don't hesitate to
let me know down below
no hard feelings this is all just for
fun if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell if you're
hungry for more black clover content we
have a full playlist of black clover
videos so you can check that out link in
the description if you feel that videos
like this one provide value for you and
you want to support more you can check
out our patreon we recently revamped the
whole thing a big thank you to all of
the patrons supporting us right now
including our pro hero to your patrons
ace 17f FDP keelon and the one and only
Gilgamesh and another huge thank you to
our two one tier patron Maddy Mac two
three nine even donating a single dollar
will give you access to our special page
and only discord and you will see your
name appear in our videos so please if
you're interested check us out link in
the description as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]